ce geste là n'existait plus depuis 40
ans dans les ateliers français
d'horlogerie c'est dire si le collage du
spirale sur le mouvement est un
événement cette pièce est aussi celle
qui fait battre le cœur de la montre
c'est ça qui va qui va permettre à la
montre de savoir l'avance et leur retard
à régler c'est un organe qui est très
important ils sont tous importants mais
celui-là c'est vraiment celui qui vient
faire battre la montre à la fin de du
montage le pari était osé assemblé en
France un mouvement livré en kit par les
Suisses un an plus tard c'est un
savoir-faire perdu qui revient un
symbole qui n'a pas échappé à certaines
grandes marques
la montre aura un fond en verre pour
qu'on voit le mouvement parce que ça me
parle d'ici quelques mois le mouvement
géant monté ici intégrera un boîtier lip
dans une montre de plongée qui sera
forcément haut de gamme on sera
sensiblement plus cher mais également on
est sur un produit beaucoup plus
technique de haute horlogerie avec des
réserves de marche beaucoup plus longues
que ce que nous avons actuellement à
l'époque fredlip avait décidé de montant
en gamme avec une collection Suisse
libre Genève et c'est vrai que le clin
d'oeil de l'histoire c'est aujourd'hui
LIP montangham avec une collection made
in Besançon une synergie qui se traduit
aussi par une collaboration de plus en
plus importante avec des acteurs locaux
ici des machines ont été achetées
spécialement pour décorer ou à jour et
la masse au silence cette pièce qui se
balance pour remonter le mouvement
la collaboration qu'on a avec eux avec
marshlabe et d'autres d'autres clients
c'est un beau projet et on est quasiment
les seuls maintenant à faire je pense en
France de la décoration de masse au
silence une personnalisation qui permet
tout simplement à la maison à berdroz de
convaincre les gens ont croit en projet
du mouvement franco-suisse parce que
effectivement depuis un an des choses se
sont passées on est à plus de 2000
mouvements montés sur site à Besançon
donc c'est réel et la confiance prendre
l'ampleur avec ça à peine voilé à ceux
qui attendaient de le voir pour y croire
[Musique]